you're releasing quick to duck in a
separate music album you gotta go both
coming up on june fourth was that always
your plan to sort of release the the
album and the movie at the Sun at the
same time no no I could say oh yeah
that's been my plan all along but no it
has it that I was coming back from
release recording the album in Kansas
City and that's when I got the phone
call at the airport literally at the
airport from the distrib so then once I
found out the dis distribution date for
the film I said why not make them both
at the same time so that's what I did so
that all happened around Christmas so it
wasn't all along I thought you know I'll
make it both the same time because I'm
that type of guy man that's I know
exactly what I want with these two
products know as soon as I got one day I
said you know let's put me here cuz
there's so much music in this film we
got my music and other people's music
it's really a lot of cool music in the
film has that been overwhelming sort of
sort of you know every year that you
know you kind of your energy is lost and
you know but each one requires so much
energy and here you are having to put
your energy into two projects two
releases how about work on releasing two
to have another one riding hanna
two-year-old and a pregnant wife and
moving to another house so overwhelming
is just the way my life is man and I
like it like that you know and I like to
keep I'd like to get things going keep
things going keep it going on it's
exciting you know I liked it's a I try
to keep sometimes I can get a little too
much going on I'm also doing a play I
wrote at the same time you know really
seeing that it's the screening of my
film the same night of playing a movie
you've heard of a dinner in a movie I'm
doing a play a movie in one night and
anyway so I like it like this and I
think that's how you have to operate as
a director and a producer you have to
have a bunch of things going on
you know and you know that but to have
two things at once being released is
exciting and I love it and do you find
that that having so many sort of things
that you're juggling like you know sort
of an energy that's created where where
they actually benefit one another well
it's taking me so many years to finally
get to products that are proud of 15
years wait 1995 what happened in 18
years of working and working and working
and working and working and finally to
have two products that I'm proud of you
know is it's just it's not overwhelming
at all it's great it's wonderful yeah
sounds like you can't wait for june for
her to get here already i'm more excited
about the next project i'm about to
process the process you know but yeah
i'm excited yeah I have a movie that's
going to be in Walmart's in all these
different places and that's great you
know I finally got you know but now I'm
thinking okay now i need a film that's
going to be in the theaters there's
always the next thing you know some
always about the next thing you know in
the process the actual process so yeah
I'm excited I'm happy about it but I
don't have time to sit around and go man
look what I did good it's not how I
think
you